it's crazy you know have a very very
blessed human being is that we are doing
that that many people are following and
watching your every move
it's not weird I guess unless you think
of it anywhere it's more of just a
humbling thing like I can't believe that
that many people are still you know
following my career I'm gonna start on
YouTube yeah March 12 belated birthday
yeah yeah what did you do did you
celebrate you know what I had a show the
next day in Hamden Connecticut so I kind
of like I went to bed right away woke up
early drove two hours there it was a
busy busy schedule so I don't really
have any time to like get crude right so
you mentioned YouTube how did all of
that start how like take us through back
to the beginning YouTube your first
video when did it go viral what happened
um well I started YouTube because my
friend kind of convinced me she told me
about this one girl who was posting
videos she had about 50 K subscribers
and [ __ ] my friends like you know you
sing better you know you could play
piano too you get way more subscribers
you should try it and I was like uh-huh
like I don't know didn't really think
about it for a while months went by and
then I finally one day during the summer
I was just like I think I want to post
something just for fun you know I was
like I love to sing I love to play and
it just became a thing people would just
ask for different songs oh can you cover
Beyonce can you cover you know some more
Miley and stuff like that can you
were you performing for other people at
that time or your first like performance
student audience was through the
internet basically that yeah I've never
really performed I do remember when I
was 12 I perform in church okay I was so
bad at being onstage I was performing a
song just like me onstage alone first
time ever and I like kind of messed up
like one lyric that no one would have
even you know thought was a mess up and
I messed it up and then like I kind of
just as soon as the song ended I like
threw the mic on the Pew of her hand to
the to the bathroom and I cried the
stall for like ten minutes and my
friends were like you know you did fine
I was like I can't do this and the
Internet you can edit you know just make
it oh yeah spot-on Internet yeah but
other than the Internet you were on the
voice so you're someone who's gone
between broadcast on television and
you've been on internet digital how do
you balance the two where do you go to
look to see how you're doing
oh do you google yourself like do you
like when there's buzz about you well
okay so my mom has like the whole Google
Alerts thing set up for me
so she'll be the one to tell me all that
stuff I don't know the first thing about
anything you know I get like my
publicist will send me you know here's
your interview here other than that I
don't I don't know do you have
notifications on your phone like all
these followers I've actually turned it
on for fun one time after the voice it
was just like Oh mom like I can't gonna
run my battery down a lot so you
mentioned your mom having Google air
it's how has your family and friends
reacted to your success over the seven
years so amazingly my family
am i speaking of my family being
supported with me my brothers actually
currently on tour with me right now
he's my tour manager I was at our player
he wears many hats and he's very
supportive any sibling rivalry fights
that happen being on tour you know what
everyone kind of asked
like you know I could say I could never
go towards my sibling my brothers you
know we get along really fast if we do
bump heads which is you know but we get
over it five ten minutes in the older
younger he's a year old
okay so he already was probably picking
on you before all this happens yeah
what's the biggest misconception people
may have about you or about being like a
YouTube star that you come across
deception yeah I know I guess well I
mean especially before the voice I think
a lot of people were just kind of
wondering how I would how I would
translate from YouTube to you know a
live stage which is honestly something I
wanted to prove to people would be
honest because you know YouTube like I
said before it's easy you know you just
edit your video down if you mess it up
you could do it again through but you
know there was a lot of you know people
wondering if people from YouTube can
translate properly the stage and so I
was really happy I got to the voice
because then economy you know and place
third hello yes which was poor and I
totally had my
and so you recently released her latest
LP a how tell us about that the album
what can we expect so it's part one of a
two-part EP I'm really excited to
release the second part but the first
part you know I just wanted to release
it to see if people would think of it
didn't want to release a completed thing
so now that I have the positive feedback
on it and everyone really seems to like
it I'm gonna be releasing the part be
beside me rather yeah and I want to
thank you know when I get back how will
you judge success at the end of this
will it be the number of followers you
have the number of albums you've sold
what like what does success mean to you
success is honestly just reaching people
that you know couldn't get reached in
any other way you know I get people
telling me things like I've been
following you for X amount of years I'm
like just recently you came out with a
song that moved me and you know like
stuff like that and I love that's why
after a show I like to stay really long
afterwards and meet everyone and hear
their stories and I love and they give
me letters like you know this is uh this
is my giant story about how I found out
about you and stuff like that so really
just inspiring people because you know
my top role models like I I met them I'd
want to tell them the same thing
no and as a youtuber that must be great
like going on tour because now not only
do people connect you like writing a
comment but you can connect with people
in person I know and it's so much fun
I'm like me I can talk to anyone like at
any time online but on tour you only get
that one city that one chance so it's
like you know I like to cherish that and
lie you die go gritty stuff like that I
love when I see posters I like you know
team Grammy signs that's pretty cool